heimet is finished I'm not a woman some
high height home for me is a place where
you can realize your freedom regardless
of where you come from or what your
background is
I'm solve items afford home for me is
the place where I feel comfortable my
original home is Rosenheim and my
academic home is Heidelberg Greece
always fascinated me my first time here
was when I was 6 for 4 weeks with my
parents it really had a lasting
impression on me George Tiffany this is
recording music for a new release the
saxophone is merely one of the many
instruments he's mastered he's nervous
man Jota type of hypothesis the music
then the music I do is called free
improvisation so there are no preset
rules instead it evolves while you're
playing live on stage so it's unique
each time various mysterion's of t Buena
onda Stein manage George moved to bond
five years ago he regularly presents
concerts in the city via a project
called the in-situ Arts Society that he
founded together with his Russian friend
Pavel Bure Auden George originally came
to bomb to study German philosophy
despite not speaking a word of German to
begin with a facts make a comment a
soldier Eastman I was an adult and I
came here advances you're used to
communicating at a certain level of
language in your mother tongue which by
definition is impossible in a foreign
country
yep indefinite Yanam in mouseland nice
terra he can and so I said about
learning German as quickly as possible
but so that I could formulate my
thoughts better my [ __ ] duncan better
formally enter cone
the Peloponnese peninsula has been
martina riedel's on/off workplace for
the last 18 months she works for the
german archaeological Institute on a
Bronze Age excavation in Terrans it's a
dream job for the 28 year old albeit a
tough one with no shortage of
competition you need a certain level of
expertise which wasn't easy at first
because I'd only just graduated from
university it's difficult to find your
way around Greek bureaucracy although
it's ok once you've got the hang of it
women Denis young man doth had a
compliment Amidala to avoid the heat
excavation only takes place in the
mornings she then returns to the
apartment she shares with other members
of the team Martina Reda lives here for
weeks at a time together with her
colleagues who hail from all over Europe
working together in such a tight space
takes some getting used to but
inevitably you do become friends so it's
really nice to meet the same people
again it's a far closer and deeper
connection than if you just see each
other occasionally
bond is similar in size to George's
hometown of Thessaloniki the first thing
he bought here was a set of wheels
he soon hooked up with movers and
shakers on the city's cultural scene and
is now an established figure himself
boost and shading teams into our society
I made a conscious decision to set up
the in-situ Art Society and be a concert
host both me and Pavel Bure Rodin's had
noticed that bond wasn't very well
served in this area here during an
ongoing excavation Martina spends her
weekends in the Greek capital Athens
life in the bustling sprawling city was
a new world for the native of provincial
Bavaria although her backyard apartment
is an island of tranquility and it's
been made even cozier by the addition of
a stray kitten she recently took in
Martinez frequent change of workplace
makes it hard to maintain personal
relationships memory rather through my
personal life needs an extra dimension
but it will come eventually and the
first year it was hard to settle in but
now I have more space and scope
today she's going shopping around Athens
with fellow archaeologists to be us but
even here they're thinking about work
the old town is home to an array of
little hardware stores where they can
stock up on tools they need for the dig
in Terrans but locals can often be taken
aback by Martinez practical mindedness
the apotheosis whew
I've often experienced intense
discussions the result in nothing and a
lot of people can't deal with my German
pragmatism first in history behind
setting up this project shows the
opposite that we are practically minded
the things we've achieved in just one
year since founding the project he would
never have imagined it so unfortunate
elbow the gorge now feels very much at
home in Bonn he's now planning to write
his doctoral thesis on the German 19th
century philosopher Hegel this little
antique books or in the old town will no
doubt come in handy George even hosts
readings here occasionally Esther was
one of the first places I went to been
born I come here pretty often because I
know I'll always find something
interesting this not this
Martyna likes to use her spare time to
explore athens on foot where she can
always discover some new relic or ruin
from the city's ancient past
now generally feel at home here
I'm no longer like a visitor I now have
my own routine which is something that
provides you with support the I mean it
was some sort of clean distance fluid
assist fumes are levels overall your
games showing that Europe with all its
different cultures is an open place it's
a big challenge we hope and often earth
is a place where you can realize your
freedom sign of high height Elysian can
for George to Pineda's freedom is in his
music and for Martina riddle the
opportunity to live and work in the
cradle of European civilization Greece
you